Oh God 50% alcohol what whoa lame-o
clean Syrian I know nothing about Syrian
food bring it on
a mimosa rock 100 proof oh I know how to
get down oh oh right no yeah like
dimetapp wrote the Tesla anvil it's
growing on me every time to the top you
heard the lady
activate the grape sucked in ha ha
Sasa change setting whoa hey black
licorice it burns it's like what I
imagined perfume tastes like I'm not
Syrian enough can't really track we are
over we're pretty tipsy hi all I think
it's gonna freak out the white in you
and get that away this is clearly
stuffed into intestines
hey Leslie and I've created hmm it
smells incredible
oh yeah there's rice again that garlic
get that garlic all on my bowels it's
this is better oh here's a guy like it
was just a branding problem
let me get past the look it's worth it
diamond meatballs - blah oh I like that
mm-hmm-hmm oh man I love it I don't know
what is that all I know is that it's
better but so briny kind of sour mucousy
creamy so powdery this yogurt it's
yogurt really right nothing is more
off-putting than the idea of warm yogurt
somebody invented this dish when they're
like oh no my yogurt it's still outside
now wait wait wait it's not 20 it's not
totally bad well lots of Meatballs hey
cutie hi oh it's like a little Bambi
Syrian pizza smells like a Jamaican beef
patty is it meat baklava smells like
pumpkin pie and sausage Cheers
mm-hmm there's even some cinnamon like a
meat pastry Oh uh-huh
there's Alyssa I would definitely hit
those oh yeah yeah I wasn't done with
that looks like something like my mom
would make this goat are there raisins
in here there's all these like great
warm spices oh my gosh this is cinnamon
II know that let's sing about it the
rest Mel that caught her mouth oh my god
Oh God happy baby baby
this is vomit so flavorful this is
everything
well melon your mouth and ribbon you
don't really need teeth for any of this
food
you call me boom Tim Tebow's this time
babe you can give me that Matt Lupe any
day tops
hey hey hey hey let's find out what meat
we're having now oh my gosh it's so
gunky hello Ajay show you a new way is
this uncooked Oh pictures just right I
can't watch you do that and then when I
eat it there's no like a floral yeah
yeah yeah and the pistachios won't quit
they are just like hmm it's all cheese
nothing oh my god wait the picture is so
sweet mmm make a wedding cake in kunafa
good marrying you seriously and you say
seriously Oh
and now the Hebb aleko asuri nailed it
yeah there are beautiful people with a
beautiful culture and beautiful food
that's good stuff yeah holy
I even lay a tear
that was the booze
[Music]